remember when your room was a blend of
half deflated furniture and pinups of
boys
great big story
[Music]
the
remembers
there was a time in history when an
inflatable chair in the corner of your
bedroom meant something
but that time is long gone
this is evangelos he's an architectural
historian we found him through the moma
he knows everything about design so one
of the first named engineers that we
know who experimented with inflatable
structures at large in the 40s was
walter bert who created enclosures and
ray domes for the military all the way
to structures that would cover open air
pools in the 1960s there is a moment
where inflatable furniture really takes
the world by storm
and ultimately in the 90s they become
part of a commercial landscape in
companies like sears
hot topic target and ultimately into
everybody's closet
right because let's be honest they were
not that comfortable
fashionable you better believe it but
practical
absolutely not
the cool clothes
when i think back to the height of
helius in the 90s you know it was the
bump toe face up shoe peeking out of a
wide leg thin fabric pants paired with
like a little baby tee with like
something printed on it
if you've never heard of delia's it was
a mail order catalog meets fashion bible
for most teen girls in the 90s and 2000s
and this is gladreal she was delia's
very first stylist
90s iconic time it was ball chain ball
chain ball chain let's wrap it once
around her neck no let's wrap it twice
around her neck okay let's wrap it six
times around her wrist okay guys can she
wear it like a wallet chain i mean we
just used ball chain for everything in
2014 delia's filed for bankruptcy but as
we all know fashion always makes a full
circle because guess what
they're
back the pin up a staple in most girls
bedrooms was the collage wall full of
cut-up boy crushes and it's likely that
most of those images came tenderly cut
from the magazine called j14
my name is richard spencer and i was the
founding editor-in-chief i created the
magazine g14 had a very specific formula
your main image is the hottest teen star
at that moment when a new band is
starting you put them smaller on the
cover if you look back at old issues you
would see that in sync or backstreet
boys were main image but then you would
start seeing incest of o-town or 98
degrees there is a common theme here and
that is boys with tight shirts on with
no shirts on we had focus groups and the
girls talked to us and they didn't like
to see any body hair they didn't want to
see armpits so that was 20 years ago so
that's changed a bit
and we can't finish this section without
talking about the pull out centerfold
it's perfect for decorating a girl's
room because the posters are wallpaper
pinups posters tomato tomato from the
original crowd of tiger beet teen dream
and the rest j14 is the only teen
magazine still left today so clearly
they're doing something right
and there you have it pieces that at one
time defined a teen girls bedroom and
some knowledge from those who knew about
them
[Music]
everybody my name is drew beebe and i'm
here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine and i wanted
to tell you about our new podcast called
great big story it's got more surprising
and delightful stories just like this
one so head over to apple podcast to
spotify wherever you get your favorite
podcasts and download great big story